and the spirit award for best supporting
mail
goes to
paul racy for sound of metal
hey now yeah independent spirit awards
let's all sign that together
independent spirit woo award
wow wow thank you thank you so much
i want to thank amazon
for the love the support the money
i'm just kidding darius martyr thank you
brother
for this opportunity thank yours for
being the best acting partner
ever my wife my daughter my guitars my
band
thank you so much and you know i've been
uh a day player for 30 years here in
hollywood but i have
one little piece of advice i can give
all of you people that are still
struggling here
don't quit your day job i never did
i still have it too
love you guys
you